en el vídeo pasado hicimos una serie de
mclaren muy sencilla la de la equis lo
que vimos es que pues se parecía
muchísimo a una combinación de las
aproximaciones polinomiales de coseno de
x y de seno de x sin embargo había
algunas cosas raras que pasaban por
ejemplo aquí había unos signos - que
aparecían y entonces si sumamos estas
dos pues no obteníamos exactamente a la
equis lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo
es presentarte un truco para poder
reconciliar estas tres expresiones el
truco va a tener que ver con los números
complejos
comencemos considerando esta expansión
polinomio al de mclaren para la equis
hasta ahorita sólo escribir una cantidad
finita de sumandos pero en realidad esta
aproximación se vuelve una igualdad
cuando digo y sigo sumando términos
todavía no lo he demostrado pero bueno
ya hablaremos de eso después en otro
vídeo pero qué sucede si tomamos en vez
de esto a la equis ya sé que puede
parecer un poco raro lo voy a poner aquí
a la equis pero bueno como que uno se
puede preguntar cómo le puedo hacer para
elevar a un número que es imaginario o
sea cómo puedo hacer una potencia a la
raíz de menos
eso suena súper raro lo bueno es que
ahora que ya tenemos una expresión
polinomio al de la equis entonces
podemos darle un cierto sentido porque
pues porque ya sabemos elevar a
diferentes potencias ya sabemos que a la
1 y al cuadrado es menos 1 y al cubo es
menos y así sucesivamente entonces qué
sucede cuando tomamos la y x una vez más
a que hay una equis y hay que cambiarla
por una y equis entonces siempre que
aquí veamos una equis en esta expresión
polinomiales simplemente vamos a poner
un equis vamos a hacer eso y ahí x nos
quedaría aproximadamente igual o bueno
igual ya sabes si tenemos una infinidad
de sumandos teníamos una igualdad y vais
a que esta igualdad si va a ser una cosa
bien profunda y a lo mejor no te puede
convencer de la importancia de esto pero
fíjate va a estar padre va a ser igual a
uno más en vez de una equis tenemos una
y equis es uno más y equis y luego hay
que sumar entonces cuánto es y x al
cuadrado entonces eso de ahí lo voy a
hacer aquí a la derecha entonces y x al
cuadrado entre 2 factorial
y al cuadrado es igual a menos 1
entonces lo hay que multiplicar por x al
cuadrado y dividir entre 2 factoriales
nos quedaría menos equis cuadrado entre
2 factorial bueno creo que más o menos
aquí se ve que es lo que va a pasar
vamos ahora con x al cubo entonces en
vez de x ponemos x entonces tenemos y x
al cubo y bueno sabes que déjame dejar
de borrar un poco esto para no saltarme
pasos
aquí nos va a quedar y x al cuadrado
dividido entre 2 factorial no no perdón
este menos 1 debería ser más entonces es
más más y x al cuadrado dividido entre 2
factoriales más y x al cubo dividido
entre 3 factorial más
y x a la cuarta dividido entre 4
factorial y así podemos seguir sumando
términos de japón uno más y x a la
quinta dividido entre cinco factorial y
más bueno así nada más sale entonces
vamos a evaluar estos y ekiza estas
diferentes potencias entonces nos
quedaría igual a uno más y equis y luego
x al cuadrado es lo mismo que y al
cuadrado por x al cuadrado y al cuadrado
es menos uno entonces nos queda menos x
al cuadrado entre 2 factorial y ahora
vamos con iu x al jugo a ver nos queda y
al cubo y al cubo es pues es y al
cuadrado por y e y al cuadrado es menos
uno entonces nos queda menos y queda
menos y por x al cubo dividido entre
tres factorial vamos a seguirle con el
quinto término el de x a la cuarta nos
quedaría más y aquí tenemos y a la
cuarta con tres ya la cuarta pues es
decía al cuadrado y eso elevado al
cuadrado entonces es menos 1 al cuadrado
que simplemente es 1
entonces y a la cuarta es uno nos queda
x a la cuarta dividido entre cuatro
factorial a ver vámonos a este de acá
nos queda pues saber y a la quinta y a
la quinta y a la cuarta por y pero y a
la cuarta ya es 1 entonces nos queda
simplemente y y por equis a la quinta
entonces 10 más y por equis a la quinta
entre 5 factorial observe que aquí ya se
empieza a ver un patrón aquí tenemos un
1 luego y luego menos 1 luego menos sí y
otra vez uno y luego seguiría un menos
uno o sea menos equis a la sexta entre a
no perdona aquí me equivoqué entre seis
factorial y luego un menos sí y luego
eso es x x a la 7 dividido entre 7
factorial va entonces bueno ya tenemos
algunos términos algunos son reales
otros son imaginarios o sea unos tienen
y otros no entonces a lo mejor lo que
nos conviene en separarlos vamos a
separar esta expresión en su parte real
y en su parte imaginaria entonces ahí x
es igual a bueno otra vez cuando tenemos
una infinidad de sumandos
a lo siguiente vamos a separar la parte
real y la parte imaginaria entonces este
es real este de aquí también es real
este de aquí es real
este también es real y ahora vamos a
poner las partes imaginarias
pero bueno déjame copiar la parte real
primero nos queda
1 - x al cuadrado entre 2 factorial más
x a la cuarta entre 4 factorial y pues
aquí ya se va poniendo emocionante la
cosa menos x a la 6 entre 6 factorial y
bueno hasta ahí es todo lo que tengo de
la parte real hasta ahorita pero pues le
voy a poner más puntos suspensivos para
indicar que sigue la suma y ahora vamos
con las partes imaginarias es decir las
partes que tienen y déjame de una vez
sacarla y porque vamos a factorizar la
entonces es más y x y x se vuelve un x y
luego el siguiente término es menos y
por x al cubo entre 3 factorial entonces
nos queda menos x al jugó entre 3
vale luego aquí tenemos un y equis a la
quinta entre cinco factorial más equis a
la quinta entre cinco factorial y nos
queda uno más el último que nos queda es
el de equis a la 7 entre 7 factorial
entonces menos x a la 7 entre 7
factorial y cierro paréntesis no sabes
que mejor le borró los paréntesis y le
sumó puntos suspensivos porque esta suma
sigue y sigue hasta infinito
entonces ya encontramos una expresión
para el ala y equis que a estas alturas
debe de tenerte sentado al borde del
asiento por la emoción porque vámonos
para arriba en los vídeos anteriores ya
habíamos encontrado esta expresión
morada como la parte polino mial o sea
como la serie de mclaren de coseno de x
fíjate es este de aquí estoy aquí es
simplemente la aproximación de taylor en
el punto x igual a 0 para cosas de x
entonces estas dos expresiones son
iguales y por tanto acá abajo voy a
indicar que esta expresión se aproxima a
coseno de x y del lado derecho
tenemos seno de x
entonces es exactamente la misma
expresión parece ser que logramos
reconciliar las expresiones de seno
coseno y algo parecido a la equis
entonces esta expresión se aproxima a
seno de x ahora si me crece esto de que
realmente cuando sumamos una infinidad
de términos las aproximaciones se
vuelven igualdades vamos a obtener un
resultado fantástico e increíble porque
como podemos resumir todo esto pues
fíjate cambiando cada una de estas
aproximaciones por las igualdades
podemos escribir que era la x es igual
es exactamente lo mismo que coseno de x
se lo voy a poner con otros colores es
coseno de x más y por seno de x esto
hasta de escalofrío es verdad más y
veces seno de x esto de aquí se llama la
fórmula de hoy leer la fórmula de hoy
leer y está buenísimo
si esto no te parece suficientemente
excitante y bueno realmente debería de
serlo ella tenemos un montón de cosas
súper padres aquí ya tenemos
viene como de interés compuesto tenemos
en el coseno que viene de cosas
trigonométricas y del círculo unitario y
también tenemos una raíz de menos 1
estoy aquí parece ser fantástico
increíble pero si no te parece lo
suficientemente impresionante o lo
suficientemente cool vamos a tomar esta
expresión de aquí vamos a suponer que
cierta y la vamos a evaluar en x igual a
pib entonces simplemente para ponerle
otro número así de estos que son así
super uso vamos a ponerle x igual aquí
entonces obtenemos el ala y por pi es
igual a es igual a jose no de pie 4 es
coseno de pie tenemos que acordarnos un
poco de nuestras relaciones
trigonométricas déjame hacer un dibujo y
es dar media vuelta al círculo unitario
entonces coseno de pies menos uno y del
otro lado tenemos seno de pi seno de pie
cero entonces este término se cancela y
y entonces qué sucede cuando evaluamos
en pi tenemos algo fantástico esto de
aquí se llama la identidad de hoy leer
la identidad
de hoy leer nos dice euler s dice hoy
leer pero bueno entonces fíjate vamos a
sumar uno de ambos lados y nos va a
quedar algo más padre lo voy a poner con
colores distintos para hacer énfasis nos
queda el elevado a la i por pi
más uno más uno es igual voy a poner la
igualdad con un color neutral es igual a
entonces como sume uno de ambos lados me
queda 0 es igual a 0
uff esto de aquí estoy aquí es una de
las cosas que más me sacan de onda en
las matemáticas y más se me hacen
increíbles y fantásticas siento yo que
hay como una conexión con el universo
que no puedo entender y viene como que
pues de esto de intentar encontrar las
raíces de todo tipo de polinomios
entonces viene pues digamos como de
sacar la raíz de menos uno
ahora vámonos con pie y es la razón
entre el perímetro de un círculo y su
diámetro este número que es interesante
por sí mismo viene de un lado muy
distinto que ahora qué es lo que pasa
con él pues viene de otros lados y viene
como de interés compuesto pero pues
también viene de esta noción de una
función cuya derivada es ella misma es
otro número fascinante parecen muy
distintos los lugares de donde vienen y
de dónde vienen
y de dónde vienen y por supuesto hasta
parece estar demás justificar porque es
0 y 1 también son importantes 1 school
por ser la identidad multiplicativo y 0
por otro lado es la identidad aditiva
entonces la identidad de hoy leer
relación a estos 5 números que son súper
importantes y súper fundamentales para
las matemáticas de una forma bien
misteriosa que no puede más que dejarme
atónito la verdad si esto no te
sorprende si no te emociona y si no te
mueve el tapete entonces no tienes
corazón